>>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
CHARLI XCX!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
♪ YOU KNOW I GO INSANE
EVERY TIME YOU HAVE TO
CATCH A FLIGHT
AH AH-AH-AH ♪
♪ CAN I TAKE YOU
TO THE AIRPORT
MAKE OUT UNDER
THE BATHROOM LIGHTS ♪
♪ AH AH-AH-AH
PUT YOUR LIPS ON MY LIPS
I'LL REMEMBER YOUR KISS ♪
♪ ON THE NIGHTS
WHEN I MISS YOU
OOH ♪
♪ SOMETHING I CAN'T FORGET
WHEN I'M RESTLESS IN BED
YEAH YOU GOT ME OBSESSED
MMM ♪
♪ OH DON'T YOU
LEAVE ME THIS WAY
WON'T YOU WAIT
ANOTHER HOUR OR TWO ♪
♪ YOU KNOW I NEED
YOU TO STAY
DON'T MAKE ME BEG FOR YOU
'CAUSE I'LL BEG FOR YOU ♪
♪♪
♪ YEAH YEAH YEAH
UH YEAH ♪
♪ BEG FOR YOU BEG FOR YOU
BEG FOR YOU BEG FOR YOU
BEG FOR YOU BEG FOR YOU ♪
♪ OH DON'T YOU
LEAVE ME THIS WAY
YOU'RE LIKE AN
OCEAN BREEZE ♪
♪ COMING AND GOING
JUST AS YOU PLEASE
AH AH-AH-AH ♪
♪ SEPARATED BY A DEGREE
HESITATE AND I LOSE YOU
SO FAR OUT OF REACH ♪
♪ AH AH-AH-AH
OH PUT YOUR LIPS ON MY LIPS
I'LL REMEMBER YOUR KISS ♪
♪ ON THE NIGHTS WHEN I
MISS YOUR MOUTH
SOMETHING I CAN'T FORGET
WHEN I'M RESTLESS IN BED ♪
♪ YEAH YOU GOT ME
OBSESSED NOW
OH DON'T YOU
LEAVE ME THIS WAY ♪
♪ WON'T YOU WAIT
ANOTHER HOUR OR TWO
YOU KNOW I NEED YOU TO STAY
DON'T MAKE ME BEG FOR YOU ♪
♪ 'CAUSE I'LL BEG FOR YOU
MY HEART IS ACHING
MY BREATH YOU TAKE IT ♪
♪ OH BABE
I JUST WANT A TASTE
DON'T YOU LEAVE
ME THIS WAY ♪
♪ DON'T MAKE ME BEG FOR YOU
DON'T LEAVE ME
DON'T LEAVE ME ♪
♪ THIS WAY
THIS WAY
THIS WAY ♪
♪ DON'T LEAVE ME
DON'T LEAVE ME
THIS WAY THIS WAY
THIS WAY ♪
♪ DON'T LEAVE ME
DON'T LEAVE ME
DON'T YOU LEAVE ME
DON'T YOU LEAVE ME ♪
♪ DON'T YOU LEAVE ME
DON'T YOU LEAVE ME
DON'T YOU LEAVE ME ♪
♪ DON'T YOU LEAVE ME
DON'T YOU LEAVE ME
YEAH
YEAH YEAH ♪
♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]